you lost your cool in an interview with
BBC's uh Andrew Neal and you're really
honest about it after which was kind of
refreshing and enjoyable
um as the internet said they've never
seen anyone lose an interview
uh so to me honestly was like seeing
like Floyd Mayweather Jr or somebody
like knocked down
um
what was that can you take me to that
experience here's that day that day is I
have a book released didn't get a lot of
sleep the night before and this is the
last interview of the day and it's an
interview with BBC I don't know anything
about BBC I don't watch BBC I know any
of the hosts so we get on the interview
and it's supposed to be about the book
and the host Andrew O'Neill doesn't ask
virtually a single question about the
book he just starts reading me bad old
tweets which which I hate I mean it's
annoying and it's stupid it's the worst
form of interview yeah when somebody
just reads you battle tweets especially
when I've acknowledged battle tweets
before and so I'm going through the list
with him and this interview was solidly
20 minutes I mean it was it was a long
interview and we get to and and I make a
couple of particularly annoyed mistakes
in the interview so annoyed mistake
number one is the ego play right so
there's a point in the middle of the
interview where I say like I don't even
know who you are which was true I didn't
know he was he turns out he's a very
famous person in in Britain and so you
can't make that equal play but even if
he's not famous it doesn't ever it's a
dumb thing to do and it's an ass thing
to do so like the so saying that was was
you know more just kind of peak and
silliness uh and uh so that was that was
a mistake I enjoyed watching that it was
like oh Ben is human yeah but
somebody enjoyed it so there is there's
that and then the uh the other mistake
was that I just don't watch enough
British TV so the way that interviews
are done there are much more adversarial
than American TV in American TV if
somebody is adversarial with you you
assume that they're a member of the
other side that's typically how it is uh
and so I'm critiquing some of his
questions at the beginning and I thought
that the critique of some of his
questions is actually Fair he's asking
me about abortion and I thought he was
asking it from a way of framing the
question that wasn't accurate and so I
assumed that he was on the left because
again I'd never heard of him uh and so
you know I mischaracterized him and I
apologize later for mischaracterizing
him we finally go through the interview
it's 20 minutes he just keeps going with
the battle tweets and finally I got up
and I took off the microphone I walked
out and immediately I knew it was
mistake like within 30 seconds at the
end of the interview I knew it was a
mistake uh and uh and that's why even
before the interview came out I I
believe I corrected the record that
Andrew Neal is not on the left that's a
mistake by me
um and uh and then you know took the hit
for for a bad interview uh and so as far
as you know what I wish I had done
differently I wish I'd known who he was
I wish I'd done my research I wish that
I I wish that I had treated it as though
there was a possibility there was going
to be more adversarial than it was I
think I was in cautious about the
interview because it was pitched as it's
just another book interview and it
wasn't just another book interview it
was treated much more adversarially than
that
um so I wish that that's on me I got to
research the people who are talking to
me and watch their shows and learn about
that and then obviously you know the
kind of gut level appeal to Ego or
arrogance like that that's a bad look
and and shouldn't have done that and
losing your cool is always a bad look